là où nous sommes il y à un ambiance de
grande tension il faut le dire il ya des
barrages plusieurs barrages autour de la
ville comme auteur de chaque ville que
nous avons traversé ces derniers
semaines les défenses des villes se
construisent petit à petit des hommes
qui attendent des heures et des heures
dans le froid qui construisent des
barrages parfois il ya même des
véhicules blindés aux entrées de la
ville il ya beaucoup beaucoup de fruits
de vic véhicules contrôle d'identité et
un énorme méfiance ici au centre
l'ukraine des titres russes en fait ce
qui est des russes qui se glisserait
dans cet arrière-pays pour perpétrer des
attentats depuis l'intérieur donc ici
tout le monde a très peur il ya
plusieurs alertes aérienne par jour donc
la vie
continue les gens qui sont dans la dans
la rue jusqu'à l'heure du couvre feu
mais c'est avec une ambiance de peur et
de méfiance plus avancés de l'armée
russe notamment au sud du pays où nous
avons été ces derniers temps la ville la
grande ville portuaire de mario paul
excusez moi dans le sud est extrême
sud-est l'ukraine est maintenant un
second cercle est de l'armée russe et
subi des tirs d'artillerie intenses nous
avons essayé de joindre nos contacts sur
place qu'on a pu avoir ces derniers
jours mais là les réseaux téléphoniques
sont coupées
nous avons rencontré ici même à
vinnytsia et et dans d'autres pays et
d'autres villes du pays des réfugiés de
mario paul qui maintenant sont sans
nouvelles de leurs proches et très très
inquiet on sait qu'il ya eu de nombreux
blessés civils et dont toutes les villes
et les ports du sud maintenant les les
attentats s'intensifie nous savons que
dans la vie des personnes qui étaient
prises par l'armée russe maintenant les
autorités locales demandent aux
habitants de rester à l'intérieur parce
qu'ils ont peur des violences ils ont
peur que il ya même des mines qui sont
placés à l'intérieur de la ville donc l
ex la situation est extrêmement tendue
et tout le monde
imagine que cette offensive du sud le
cren de l'ukraine va continuer parce que
il ya des cibles fortement intéressant
au niveau
stratégique la ville d'odessa et ses
draps et on peut imaginer que
l'intention russe et de créer ce couloir
au sud de l'ukraine pour lier le donne
basse jusqu'à la crimée